[Música]
cada año el mundo consume 35000 millones
de barriles de petróleo esta escala
masiva de dependencia de combustibles
fósiles contamina la tierra y no durará
para siempre los científicos estiman que
ya se ha consumido un 40% del petróleo
del mundo y que a ese ritmo nos
quedaremos sin petróleo y gas en 50 años
y sin carbón en aproxim ente un
siglo por otro lado tenemos abundante
sol agua y viento fuentes de energía
renovables que no las agotar con el
tiempo Qué pasaría si sustituyamos los
combustibles fósiles por las energías
renovables hemos reflexionado sobre eso
durante décadas y sin embargo la energía
renovable solo abastece el 13 por de
nuestras necesidades Eso es porque
alcanzar el 100% requiere energía
renovable que sea eica y
accesible esto representa un gran
desafío Incluso si ignoramos la política
involucrada y nos enfocamos en la
ciencia y la ingeniería para entender
mejor el problema podemos observar el
uso de energía global un sistema diverso
y complejo y los elementos que requieren
sus propias soluciones pero ahora nos
centraremos en los dos usos cotidianos
más comunes la electricidad y los
combustibles líquidos la electricidad
Los Altos hornos ascensores computadoras
y todo en hogares negocios y
manufactura Mientras tanto los
combustibles líquidos juegan un papel
crucial en casi todas las formas de
transporte consideremos primero la parte
eléctrica nuestra tecnología ya es lo
suficientemente avanzada para capturar
toda esa energía de las energías
renovables y hay gran
oferta el sol continuamente irradia
alrededor de 173 cuatrillones de vatios
de energía solar a la tierra que es casi
10,000 veces nuestras necesidades
actuales se ha estimado que se
necesitaría una superficie de varios
cientos de miles de kilómetros para
alimentar a la humanidad
actualmente Entonces por qué no
construimos eso porque hay otros
obstáculos como la eficiencia y el
transporte de energía para maximizar la
eficiencia las plantas solares deben
ubicarse en áreas de mucho sol todo el
año como desiertos pero esos están muy
lejos de las regiones densamente
pobladas donde la demanda de energía es
alta hay otras formas de energía
renovable como la hidroeléctrica
geotérmica y biomasas pero también
tienen límites en función de la
disponibilidad y la
ubicación en principio una red de
energía eléctrica conectada a través del
mundo nos permitiría transportar energía
desde donde se genera a donde se
necesita pero un tema a esta escala
tiene un precio
astronómico podríamos reducir el costo
al desarrollar tecnologías avanzadas más
eficientes la infraestructura para
transportar energía debería cambiar
drásticamente las líneas eléctricas
actuales pierden del 6 al 8% de la
energía porque el material de alambre
derrocha la energía por la
resistencia las líneas eléctricas más
largas significarían más derroche los
superconductores podrían ser una
solución Porque pueden transportar
electricidad sin
derroche Lamentablemente solo funcionan
a bajas temperaturas lo que requiere
energía y frustra el objetivo por lo
tanto habría que descubrir materiales
superconductores que operen a
temperatura
[Música]
ambiente y los importantes combustibles
líquidos derivados del petróleo el
desafío científico es almacenar energía
renovable de forma fácilmente
transportable recientemente se mejoró la
producción de baterías de iones de litio
que son livianas y tienen densidad de
alta energía pero las mejores almacenan
alrededor de 2.5 megajulios por kg que
es aproximadamente 20 veces menos que la
energía en un kg de gasolina para ser
realmente competitivas las baterías de
automóviles tendrían que almacenar más
energía sin agregar
costo los desafíos aumentan para naves
Grandes como barcos y
aviones para impulsar un vuelo a través
del Atlántico necesitaríamos una batería
de unas 1000
toneladas y un salto tecnológico hacia
nuevos materiales mayor densidad de
energía y mejor
almacenamiento una solución sería
encontrar formas eficientes de convertir
energía solar en energía
química esto ya sucede pero con una
eficiencia demasiado baja para permitir
que llegue al
mercado para encontrar soluciones
novedosas necesitaremos mucha
creatividad Innovación e
incentivos la transición hacia energías
totalmente renovables es un problema
complejo que involucra tecnología
economía y política la prioridad al
abordar este reto depende de los
supuestos específicos que tengamos para
resolver un problema tan
multifacético Pero hay muchas razones
para ser optimistas de lograrlo las
Mentes científicas más importantes del
mundo están trabajando en ello y
avanzando todo el tiempo y muchos
gobiernos y empresas están invirtiendo
en tecnologías que aprovechan la energía
alrededor quies saber más sobre las
apasionantes medidas que los científicos
responsables políticos y personas como
usted están tomando para garantizar el
futuro de nuestro planeta visite
ed.ted.com
barclin scho para alimentar su
curiosidad y su esperanza